de tanto repetirlo Maki Mohamed memorizó
la inscripción que el ex dictador Sadam
husein ordenó tallar en los ladrillos
utilizados en la reconstrucción de la
antigua Babilonia en 1988 construyeron
esta parte más atrás fue en 1989
como lo hizo Nabucodonosor II
considerado el más grande de quienes
reinaron el Imperio Babilonia
se obsesionó con dejar su legado en este
lugar considerado cuna de la humanidad
construyó su Palacio en lo alto de las
ruinas a las que quería devolver su
grandeza
la nueva Babilonia duró 2600 años Fue
obra del famoso rey de la nueva
Babilonia que empezó a construirla en el
año 605 antes de Cristo maquin Mohamed
nació en estas planicies y su familia
trabajaba en Babilonia por generaciones
su mayor preocupación es la conservación
del lugar
muchos de los turistas iraquíes que la
visitan son extremadamente jóvenes y no
son conscientes de la importancia de
cuidarla pero su mayor dolor de cabeza
fue durante la invasión estadounidense
en 2003 las tropas extranjeras
levantaron uno de sus campamentos en los
alrededores de la ciudad estaban dentro
de la ciudad antigua había vehículos
blindados cerca del monumento del león
su aeropuerto estaba detrás de estos
árboles sus vehículos y soldados
tuvieron un impacto negativo en la
ciudad antigua fue encarcelado por dos
meses la razón para la detención fue
pedirle a una soldado que no se llevara
uno los ladrillos milenarios me ataron
las manos a la espalda y me pusieron una
bolsa negra en la cabeza me llevaron a
su base cerca de la cuerda de estar y
luego me metieron en la cárcel me ataron
las manos durante aproximadamente un mes
me torturaron y eso me afectó
negativamente me presionaron los huesos
me quedan estas cavidades dos décadas
después la vida recuperada una cierta
normalidad cada días visitado por más
turistas algunos de ellos extranjeros
que poco a poco vuelven a regresar para
alegría de Maki Mohamed Siempre listo a
explicar cómo era esa Babilonia una de
las ciudades más antiguas de la
civilización